it is february 27 2022 and you are
watching the code report war what is it
good for absolutely nothing unless you
are a power hungry psychopath running
the world who profits from the
military-industrial complex if that's
you then war is [ __ ] awesome but what
does war mean for the future of the
internet and software development nobody
knows but here are some possibilities
all of which are purely speculative one
this whole thing blows over in a couple
of weeks and we're back to normal and
the golden age of coding resumes that's
the best case now the worst case is
world war 3 breaks out most men and
women trade in their keyboards putting
their silly apps and nft collections on
hold then courageously march into the
meat grinder of war that would obviously
be bad because it's hard to learn python
when you're getting shelled in a trench
but another potential outcome that would
be a lot more interesting for developers
is a cyber war your friends over at the
world economic forum have been preparing
for a cyber war for a long time there's
an annual event called cyber polygon
where all the big banks and tech
corporations get together to simulate a
global internet crisis frightening
scenario
of a comprehensive cyber attack
which would bring
to a complete heart
to the power supply
transportation hospital services our
society as a whole
the cobai 19 crisis
would be seen in this respect as a small
disturbance
in comparison to a major cyber attack
no internet no power grid that would
suck balls banks and bitcoin wouldn't
work anymore no whatsapp twitch twitter
or youtube people get really bored and
they'd be forced to talk to their
neighbors face to face that's a
horrifying thought for developers
however when the dust settles it might
mean a great reset of the internet as we
know it what that might look like is
anybody's guess and in all likelihood
the government would make it less
private and more regulated in the name
of global security but it would be an
interesting thing to live through
nonetheless and javascript developers
would rise straight to the top of the
social dominance hierarchy in some ways
the cyber war has already started
because russia and the united states
have traded cyber attacks in the past
and the propaganda outlets are preparing
us for an even bigger crisis i was
actually the victim of a cyber attack
myself just recently where the attackers
tried to test thousands of stolen credit
cards on my website luckily i use
firebase which will automatically absorb
any ddos attacks at layer 4 and below
and i was able to use cloud audit to get
more information about the incoming
requests the coolest thing though is
that firebase has a feature called app
check that can automatically block any
request to your database or cloud
functions unless they come directly from
your front end application and that
makes automated attacks to your
infrastructure much more difficult the
bottom line is that now is the time to
make sure your apps are secure
realistically though the most likely
outcome from this whole ukraine crisis
is all-out nuclear war in which case
we're all going to die a horrible
horrible death so my recommendation is
to continue to learn to code and get
your app shipped before the internet is
gone forever this has been the code
report thanks for watching and peace out
[Music]